hi this is dr. ken jongo of dr. ken and
welcome to Doc's support my first
question from Ashley at queasy baked how
do I know if I have the stomach flu or a
hangover
well honey did you drink last night mmm
glug glug did you have food or did you
have alcohol the Internet is not for
stupidity ma'am the Internet is for
smart established doctors like me and my
friend Luis here think before you tweet
okay another question okay Kellie
underscore Sheridan one finally a great
question how much vitamin C is too much
yes sometimes too much vitamins is too
much you always get these things on
medical shows going like should I take
this supplement should I take this
supplement and honestly you can get
hypervitaminosis like if you go to GNC
or some other stories don't say like oh
this you get like 2,000 percent of the
recommended daily allowance of vitamin
you know see you can actually get side
effects and symptoms or GI symptoms from
too much vitamins so it's probably good
just to get like a hundred percent of
the recommended daily allowance that's
really all you need
great question kelly sheridan i'm not
supposed to pick favorites they told me
not to the producer but you're my
favorite Appetit macaroon so it's like a
weird skin tag under my eye that hurts
when i rip it off what's up with that
skin tag is it called a skin polyp in
real life is render it can be anywhere
along your body i think to rip off any
lesion that you don't know about right
under your eye I mean honestly I can't
think of a more ill-advised stupid move
than that they can no up the area clip
it off I've actually when I practice
medicine
someone had skin tags on their arm or
extremities it always freeze it off with
liquid nitrogen and it doesn't hurt I
highly recommend that you have a
professional remove it professionally at
captain handlebar ass now can we address
the knee reflex tests at the doctor's
office this has to be useless right no
it's not useless
we're not monkeys that use these just
for props we're not the carrot top of
doctors here and I can just show you
right here this is a neat there's a
tendon that connects the knee to the leg
bone okay called the tibia there's a 10
in here you want to check the reflex of
this you go oh let me just check that
and what that does me it's actually it
checks really your whole nervous system
in many ways to see that if your
reflexes are intact low thyroid levels
in your body or which is very common
called hypothyroidism you actually will
be hypo or flexing and you would not be
able to elicit much of a reflex
so this sucker is very important okay
don't mock our tools okay we're pros and
we're sensitive emotionally mm-hmm busy
so to ask how do you check your pulse
could check it here you check it here
even check it here on your leg
a baby could tell you how to check a
pulse oh no no you can't you can't ask
any question on Twitter just don't
defend shut up
I'm sorry I see that it's just me and
Lois gotten the whole thing whatever
okay moving on bujji Okubo says do I
really need both my kidneys you know
what that's part of the whole area of
like kidney transplantation we've heard
of people donating kidneys to other
people in need who have kidney failure
technically one can survive with just
one kidney if it's as long as this
normally functioning really good
question hope I have more questions like
this at Haley Nesbitt one says why do I
always get cramps or spasms in my full
leg nearly every day hashtag ouch
hashtag doctor help nurse Lee for me
that I would definitely get checked out
leg pain or like spasm can be due to a
multitude of things instead of saying
what those hundred things are you
actually need to see a physician for
that determine is it your illogical a
nation in nature is a tender penological
in nature it can be do a lot of
different things okay good question okay
at hice underscore sai underscore EHS
quick what are the three parts of the
brainstem first one to reply with the
correct answer could surprised study
test tomorrow smiley emoji with glasses
okay so um three parts of the brainstem
are the medulla the pons and the
midbrain and the medulla I believe
control the breathing and the pons links
a cerebellum to the cerebrum and the
midbrain
rooo demanding a vision and hearing all
for me didn't have to look it up I'm a
smart man shut up I forget all right
I've been busy doing hangover movies
at Wigan underscore Stephen ask any
doctors on here can I drink alcoholic
substances while taking a rhythmic pen
antibiotics hashtag doctor help hashtag
doctors you know what actually that's a
great question erythromycin which is
what erythro pet is a trademark name for
it can upset the stomach and also is
metabolized in the liver so I would
check with your doctors see exactly how
much antibiotics are taken i generally
discourage any taken any alcohol while
on antibiotics because a lot of
antibiotics are metabolized in the liver
you don't want to like overload them
with too much things that can be toxic
to your liver all right they sing 14s
what's the part of the brain that's
going to deal with my emotional
breakdown tomorrow a hashtag AP psych
there's many parts your brain that's
gonna be dealing with kind of stress to
take a test so I wish you the best of
luck
and I know you'll do well alright that's
do bunny ask if anyone has any ideas for
how to do a science headache and
pressure I'm open to hearing if it's
been going on for weeks at a time I
would actually consider antibiotics now
I would consider going to your general
practice doctor or even your nose throat
doctor an ENT doctor to get treatment at
dr. Claire Kane says help need emergency
hiccup cure before clinic starts in
approximately five minutes same scare
Jim all right at lice the pits
why is my eye twitching oh my god stop
first of all probably stop using words
like oh my god stop maybe get some more
sleep
drink less caffeine alright next at CD
101 I wan burp but why can't I I don't
know I'm not your diaphragm at cbs- 540
my kidneys hurt it's drinking a lot of
water a bad thing any doctors on here
actually drinking too much water can
lead to some problems I would actually
go see a general practice doctor and get
your sodium level check because you
don't want to have too much hyponatremia
anyway that's dr. support on dr. ken
Jeong if dr. Ken and I would like to
thank some of you on Twitter for your
amazing questions and the others you
suck
you really do shut up Louis they do